The joe rogan experience.
He travels,
he's worldwide.
I won't lie to you.
I travel a great deal.
What were we talking about right before the podcast started where it says you
have to set and you have to bring this up on the podcast about about,
um,
so I did a podcast today with a guy from cracked.com Dan O'brian wrote a really
funny book called how to fight presidents.
He literally took every president in the history of America to see who is the
baddest ass,
who's the one guy you wouldn't want to fight and who would win in a fight if
they were pitted against each other.
It's like it's in some ways the greatest book of all time.
And like I said,
I go,
this is the,
this is going to be the greatest podcast both times.
It was the funniest thing because we got to know a heavy heated argument about
who would win in a fight.
And you got to put a couple of presidents up at the top of the list.
You got to put a Blinken cause he was renowned for his physical strength.
There it is.
It's a thug.
He fought vampires to right.
Well,
he did,
but he used the movie.
He used an ax,
but Abe Lincoln was six,
four and had,
what's that disease where your arms are longer,
you have really long arms,
like longer than your body had crazy island.
And he was,
he was known to be really strong and,
and very,
very tough.
Acute [inaudible] I'm starting to also want to say was,
I think you also have to think of people that lived during that era.
There were a lot tougher.
They grew up doing everything with their hands,
right.
Building things.
Andrew Jackson was a gentle,
I mean,
he committed a little something called genocide.
And you talked to historians.
They're like,
well,
he killed a great deal of native Americans with extreme prejudice.
So he hit,
I don't know what he's still,
that's not,
I wouldn't,
that's a strong word.
Funny you say,
well,
hold on Steve.
I don't think disease transmission counts.
I agree with you.
Is that what he did leave?
He did.
He was a soldier and,
and did,
I mean he was,
uh,
he,
he clearly probably killed a lot of men with his bare hands.
I mean that was bare hands,
but certainly with a gun or a knife.
I mean he was a pretty warlike fella and in fact challenged.
He had a number of duals.
Historians are actually,
uh,
he got shot and live most of his life with a bullet in his rib cage.
Shitty guns back then,
but he had to clean three.
There's a debate how many duals he actually had.
When you have,
when there's a debate on how many duels fucking president,
you're a bad mother fucker or you're an idiot,
right?
You keep getting a duels.
Well,
he got shot because he let the guy take the first shot.
He goes,
take the first shot guy shot him.
Then he shot the guy and live that way for the rest of his life.
He,
he had,
he had a gaping wound that would,
you know,
cause problems periodically and you take the first shot
you got to Andrew Jackson,
who was 62 he was struck,
he had to be drawn to the George Washington 64 who was a tough guy.
George Washington was six four he was,
people weren't that big that they know he was a giant.
I'll tell you six for Jesus Christ.
George Washington was,
it's a small solar,
so it's yours.
Washer could have beat
my money on Doug.
George has wooden teeth.
He's got a fucking goofy wig on.
You pull that wig off.
He's all insecure about his hair.
Yeah,
you pull that off.
He's not going to know what the fuck to do.
He's going to search for his wig.
You kick him in the Dick.
Next thing you know,
you're pulling out his wooden teeth and beating the shit out of him.
Got My money on.
But then there was Lyndon Johnson who's also six four but Teddy Roosevelt who
practice,
who boxed,
wrestled and practiced judo with the guy who brought judo to the United States,
the first judo guy.
And was obsessed with all things wrestling and fighting.
He was about five,
10 and very thick,
but it very sickly kid died of heart disease.
How do we cart?
So I don't know.
My thing is Gerald Ford played football and could have played for the bears as a
middle linebacker.
That says a lot when you play in the NFL.
So I might have to go with a,
we had a huge discussion about this for a good hour.
I go with Luke Bryan Callen show and a,
it was a good time.
I got Lincoln.
So no,
that's not what you were talking about.
What are you talking about?
So then he said,
I said,
what about Barack Obama?
And he got quiet there.
Dan's a comedian,
really good guy.
He got quiet and they said,
well,
I can't really,
you know,
I,
I'd rather leave that alone.
I said,
why?
He said,
well,
I tried not to,
you try not to include any living presidents because it causes too much trouble.
I said,
what do you mean?
He said,
well,
I went through sort of a thing about how,
you know,
Barack Obama's not that tough of president and it'd be easy to kick his ass.
And uh,
you know,
I was doing it tongue and cheek.
You know,
you'd probably kick him here and he's kind of skinny and you could do,
and he gets a call from the secret service because he posted it as a blog.
You Post it as a blog come from cracked.com.
Well,
he said the reason the only blog that's not up there anymore is that because he
got called down to the federal building,
I believe.
I think that's what he said.
It's on my podcast.
And he had to go line by line with these agents on what he meant by what he was
saying.
And he was like,
well,
I said,
you know,
I said a Dick Tornado instead of a penis cycling because it's kind of funnier.
He was trying to teach them for humor.
These guys were totally fucked.
He got all nervous.
He was like apologizing.
He made them edit,
take it down.
And it was a chapter that was isolated from the book.
I'd be like,
so that I was like,
we live in America.
How now you have to be careful when you've threatened the president,
you will get called.
But guys,
guys,
come on.
Come on man.
I mean,
and,
and he took,
probably we can't,
they probably can't.
Well that's his probably nowhere to go.
Like,
yeah,
they probably knew.
Of course he's joking,
but there's a thing that you set in motion a certain status.
What happens?
Because they say,
we,
we will subpoena everybody that made a comment on your,
on the blog,
kick his ass,
and,
and Dan said,
well,
it's a bunch of 14 year olds have fun with that.
And the,
the main guy had called them first.
He goes,
look,
I know you're kidding.
I know you got a sense of humor.
You've got to go down and talk to these guys.
It's just the way it is,
pal.
Okay.